the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by me undies listen you
want to look good in your underwear and
be comfortable correct
but that perfect balance is hard to find
don't sacrifice style or comfort check
out meundies.com and find the best bear
underwear in the world i'll tell you
what i'm going to do for you right now
because it's the fall you want to look
good i'm going to get you 20 off free
shipping and the 100 satisfaction
guarantee
and that you're going to get the best
and softest underwear you'll ever own do
me a favor go to the undies.com joey
again that's me undies.com
joey
you all want to eat better but when it
comes to snacks sometimes it feels
like the whole world is delicious and a
billion calories versus boring and
tasteless i mean hey i don't like eating
carrots either you know it doesn't have
to be that way up your snack game with
naturebox
you're sure to find your new snack
obsession at naturebox and right now
you'll save even more
naturebox is offering the church family
three free snacks with your first order
when you go to naturebox.com
joey that's naturebox.com
joey for three free snacks with your
first order that's naturebox.com
slash joey kick that [__] mule
lee
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [__]
dig
[Music]
here we go [__]
what's up you [__] savages uncle joey
here
it's monday the 18th tomorrow's the 19th
by the time you're listening so get your
[__] together
if you came to the cherokee indian
casino last weekend i want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart i had a
great time i'm sorry i couldn't take the
joints but we had eyes on us from all
[__] directions
the cherokee casinos they the the
cherokees they watch you
in the house we got my girl eleanor
martinez yes aka eleanor kerrigan
and the christ killer of the original oh
lee
from israel and [__] i was just on a
mission to israel
you need to [__] today they got
together did you see they put an airport
jews the air force oh put a [__] base
in israel it's the first ever nice i
feel like that this i'll up in that game
did you help out no you don't i i can
neither confirm nor deny they got that
they got this [__] tight to attack korea
now that's [__] yeah they'll be working
with the [__] jews krav maga coming
at you my dad fought in korea he's ready
to get back in he says he's suiting up
right now girl
ain't gonna work against those [__]
those krav maga [__] but anyway
we're here with queer
we're talking about interesting things
listen man everybody strives to be the
best they can be right
when you start playing that competition
game and comedy
or just [__] on other people it's the
[__] out of the comics and the uh
the comparing comparing yourself to what
you have and what you don't have to
other comics the same thing works in
life yeah while you're focusing on what
you don't have and they have
you're [__] up instead of focusing on
what you need and how you're gonna
[__] get it yeah
yeah you know when i walk to the store
and i walked down the aisle and
and and uh sebastian bilber
and uh the [__] savage that we had on
the show ron white
how great is he
you know
what do you want me to do you want me to
sit there and cut a chicken's head and
throw it on their ankles
you know what i'm saying what do you
want me to do
oh yeah they're going to
sit there
and say well they got this so i hate
them because of that you can't do that
that's what gets comics [__] dead i
lost that little thing i had like in 98
when you're here for two years you get
it yeah you start to get it because
you're not going to montreal
you're not getting an agent comics that
you moved here with that aren't as funny
as you
are getting [__] three yards to rep
them
and you're not getting nothing so you
get a little bitter but then one day you
come to the conclusion that listen i
have a job to do regardless of what the
[__] they're doing
and you move on you stay in your lane
like i always treat it like swimming i
was always a swimmer i swam
competitively i was a chain smoker too
so that [__] everything up but
but when you swim if you look at the
other swimmers you fall behind that's it
it's the first rule my sister taught me
that when i was eight and i always did
that my whole life just
stay straight look people are gonna pass
you you know you might not win that
[__] race but you're still in the
race
we're still all in the race you know now
you and i both see we've been both here
i've been here for 20 years i've been
here since 93 i've known you the whole
time now
lee had an interesting question we were
talking before the podcast yes i swallow
no no no i'm sorry it's funny that
that's good
actually there's people that we've known
over the years
that you've they've been lingering at
the store and you sit there and watch
them
and you start to feel bad when they come
over and talk to you they talk to you
about their plans and what's going to
happen if it doesn't work
and now they're not getting this and
then again when i got to the store there
were 10 of those guys that hang out at
the store every night
pissing on your [__] leg
and some of them actually have
psychological problems like if you
really look at from outside not that i'm
no [__] saint
but i'm looking at these guys going how
can they not realize what is going on
around them
they've been here for 15 years they've
had minimal success
and now two generations are passing them
up younger than them yeah
at some time
you have to say be honest with yourself
and go you know what
i either gotta figure something out
quickly
or excel to the next level of this
whatever it is whether it's writing
uh coaching
you know something listen phil jackson
was not the best basketball player in
the world and he ended up becoming the
best coach in the world yeah the dynasty
okay i know guys that are tremendous
fighters
that are great jiu jitsu guys that have
won thousands of competitions and they
run shitty jiu jitsu schools
i know guys that uh have one stripe
black belts and they run a school like
it's a [__] temple
so
not everybody can transition into
everything you have to know when it's
time to move on
i'm very every year i have to pray that
you know though no every year that's
hard that's the scariest part is every
year i had a [__] checklist december
31st
yeah to be honest with myself and i and
i got to be honest when i got here guys
i had plans for something it didn't look
like it was going that way
i had plans to be a stand-up but there
was no love in the stand-up community
except for mitsy shaw
so i returned to acting to go through
the back door i'm not ashamed to say
that
my lucky thing was the sopranos hit i
looked like the guy
so i was getting hired for a lot of jobs
on the basis of that yeah that's fine
i'll take it yeah i'll take it i was in
prison 15 years ago this is i'll take it
right i'll take it however they [__]
serve it up
you know now again you got to go well
joey you got lucky no no no i was there
for the opportunity yeah i was there for
the opportunity for the opportunity to
pay for the opportunity i walked into
mad tv and every year i had a certain
goal yeah every year i had a certain
[__] thing and the goal was if it
didn't work out i made myself a promise
why waste people's time my time and
everybody else is you are what you are
i'll move back to ludberg and get a
little hot like a [__] pablo
basketball i do that to my mom all the
time and wait till i die yeah the cops
come get me or i end up in prison that
was the truth that was the game plan
white kid even when i was sleeping in
that [__] car
i was making moves yeah i was still
[__] uh just because i didn't have an
apartment i was still getting four spots
a week at the store
still getting 10 22 all around town
that's where felipe had a room
where we had a room like i've ever flown
you know everybody had a [__] room
everybody had two or three rooms so i
was making a living i just didn't have a
[__] apartment yeah but you're still
hustling that's what's driving your your
opportunity preparation meets
opportunity so you're preparing yourself
for a soon-to-be opportunity hopefully
that comes sometimes these people
they're out here they just think oh
they'll just come find me you know i'm
just hanging out at the right place at
the right time no [__] you got to be
prepared you got to be able to back it
up you could get a job and it just like
it puts you over the top but then you
have nothing else after that nothing you
know what i mean you get one job
everybody's like oh this guy's great or
this girl's great and then that job ends
and they get nothing else because they
can't back up
what happened to the dude from that
[__] movie
tino speaks what was that skinny dude
that they gave him that rollerblade
movie with your boy i don't i'm so happy
about all that will current whatever his
[__] name is will will pharaoh will
fire on him oh you're talking about the
uh okay the guy from uh
the pedro
the big curly hair guy the skinny blonde
guy the aria
yeah where is he today
the red-headed ari because i remember
when we saw that movie dice was like
ahri missed out
i was like you are dancing i've seen him
recently i feel like but he still works
he actually looks normal right that but
that was a guy that they blew up they
blew smoke in his ass
and he fell apart at the [__] seams
he was not ready for it right he was not
prepared for what they gave you know
that movie that a lot of people don't
know this that movie that [__] what's
his name the chubby kid got nominated
for an academy award with brad pitt oh
um jonah hill that was demetrius
martin's role he got fired
oh really
demetrius martin the comic demetrius the
guitar player yeah well
he's like a prop and [__] college kids
like him yes that was his role
yeah i'm not mad at me
he did really well jesus christ well
this guy works a lot he does like a ton
of shorts
yeah
he's all over the place that guy he
didn't like disappear he just did what
he wanted but he's coming back no he
didn't do what he wanted they gave him a
comedy central show ten episodes and he
couldn't come with a spread that was oh
it was all oh really yeah that was the
end of that yeah i thought he was into
his own let me do my own yeah
sure
what are you gonna do with short films
wait for them to go to a festival my
phone got into a festival that's great
that the [__] you paid 250. so your
film could be in a [__] festival can
you imagine that some people that's
their world that's their world yeah and
that's what they do and that's fine if
you're happy do it [__] it man but to be
i thought the festival world was dead
for me it died
i was in ten films one with james coburn
i did ten films that all went to [__]
festival that's amazing and nothing ever
happened not a [__] call i did i had
a film in the gay film festival
that i can't kind of film i would love
to get in i got i had a film at the gay
film festival in hollywood
10 million [__] gay men in the
industry
and i didn't even get to suck a dick not
even not even nobody called me for a
booty call you understand me
i was in the gay film festival and not
one [__] call no i was in the they
didn't say we want the cuban bear no i
was in the one big
festival the one year with that [__]
movie
with that one toronto film festival oh i
had three movies in the toronto film
festival that's some guts i had another
movie that i played a [__] salesman
with a kid and we were alone we lived in
a car
that was supposed to get nominated for
[__] 10 bammies i was going to walk
the red carpet with marky roberg oh my
god nobody's called i did another one
with those dudes from [__]
he's big now
i just saw him in something oh i just
saw him in uh ballers he played he
played great show owner agm's brother
okay he played the owner's brother i did
a pilot with him where he was a boy
scout [__]
troop and i sold heroin at an italian
restaurant they sold heroin but they
dress up like boy scout leaders and come
into the place that was supposed to go
to [__] you know i did a thousand of
those things i've been a thousand
festivals i tried everything to get in
those festivals that's amazing see it's
like
six or one half a dozen of another like
i want that i want to get a [__] i
was in the jersey film festival i did
comedy at the [__] thing
and still bombs you understand me
i still didn't get who got it not
nothing i got a call a year later for
some [__] commercial regional i
thought i was going to replace meryl
streep but i kept getting to play a
[__] plumber so for me i swear to god
i'll play so for me
the festival game didn't work it may
work for some other people i thought
that i would get one i was in the gay
film festival and i was in the second
page it's amazing the top short film was
that the guy who [__] directed and
wrote it was the king of the gays in
hollywood i loved him barry diller no we
still talk we still oh like i see what
that has the best
job in hollywood wow you know what he
does what he directs those videos
for people when they buy a bed at those
places no no what's that [__] place
you buy furniture at sleepy's you build
it yourself oh ikea yeah
so you build a bed when you buy a
[__] couch from ikea
that comes with a video yeah you pop
that video in he shoots all those things
dog he's making six figures he works
eight to five you know
with nobody no [__] they're all the
same they're all the same you really he
was like god loved him i came on here
with these big dreams
and he goes they all sucked because did
the show but he's making a living the
movie i did for him
was a tv show originally okay it was the
reason why [__] left the sopranos
besides they hated his guts and the
whole [__] yeah yeah but they didn't
really like him one of the reasons was
he was going to do this at abc
abc wanted to take a walk on the wall
side and do a show about two game
mobsters in hollywood
that they're [__] were you gonna
co-star with them
no no no so big [__] was doing this it
was him and my louie
the one kid that goes to the store and
their [__]
headquarters was the hollywood pussycat
theater oh hilarious this guy these guys
did write something very funny yeah but
at the last minute abc got cold feet i
was gonna say that that's so weak too
early for somebody
right now in 2002 the sopranos were on
fire so every network was trying to come
up with a mob show
to go operations
right right
they had a long [__] talk they looked
at mickey mouse
and they said we like our jobs forget
the gate thing
we'll put a gate thing later on as a
co-star
like now i feel like you could do
something like that maybe on hbo or
something like it it was great it would
be great i thought it was funny and a
little bit darker listen i don't know
how to find the [__] thing but it's
acceptable more now what should i put in
mesos the mezzos m-e-z-z
apostrophe s your boy
your boy went in there with me to read
on a saturday we read together he read
by himself
when i got the movie he was furious
he talked [__] for a [__] month
he was better than the guy the guy could
have been a lot better you can't say his
name no all right who's your boyfriend
i have so many no yeah
oh who's your main lover and he'll
[__] leave his wife and kids
to be with you
look there's so many of us
oh
i was so high on coke that morning like
i'm gonna punch you this was so [__]
amazing i was falling asleep from the
night before
and i drank two red bulls
you look great though
does it have a volume to it
that's just high gun
now there's a fenugreeker or a full
blown what it means like a half a [__] or
a full flower full face what stay facts
do you feel better i guess
let's go come on shut the [__] up we
just got here pray or something
i don't pray no more
what the [__] you mean you know praying
i'm praying that it's a stupid brain you
want to go to hell or something no it's
not like that i just don't pray no more
give it up for lent
you cannot give up praying for lent you
are positively a [__] now you have to
give up something you like
like eating
holy [__] you watch your [__]
mouth
i can't you [__] i'm telling you
for everyone watching now
there's like a hot dude that's lee
with bosses in my dreams
dog i'm telling you i was in the gay
film festival
with this movie
i walked in there [__] people were
shaking my hands oh my god that [__]
smile right there at the end i want to
beat you oh my god
santa monica boulevard
oh yeah look at this it was a spoof
and a half dog
and it was me and this kid until today i
still talk to this kid
we still talk once every three months
can you believe this [__] that fulfilled
it oh you want to keep blaming okay yeah
yeah there's some good [__] that's
amazing you can't [__] believe this
dog this had to be
you know 14 years ago it's kind of the
opening is soprano-esque
yeah
yeah they did i mean it's a little
different obviously it's the west coast
versus the yeah they did this
and fox search lab was all over this it
was a map
this was the first real short film i
ever did i think you must have been
dropped on your head when you was living
that hat
so your brother's gay we're both gay
what are we doing here again you missed
his last three payments
how much this guy owes 7 500 times
people
the hell would i know you still talk to
him
i believe it is sir andrew light weapon
what's this guy's name i don't know i do
know that sondheim writes music but i
can actually listen to as opposed to
most composers i think the louder the
noise the instruments make the better
the song
this got me analyzed
it's amazing yeah see this is the tape
i'm thinking it's fine it's this is the
tape i said frank why is that
she told me what the [__] are you
talking about another tape when i got a
thing and i sent it to her and i can i
sent this to the sopranos too she told
me to send there anything i did yeah
that would help my cause i've never even
seen cats
yes
twice with you with you
anything on my teeth no no you're good
you're good
besides the composer does not control
the volume of the instruments do not
the conductor does
oh ring it again
thank you
i hope not
i think you've been influenced by the
commercial success of mr webber's
productions as opposed to maybe forming
your own opinion you know
if i didn't know any better i swear you
were straight
hello mrs uh
bambini
i thought you didn't know his name i
don't know his first name
this is bambini it's your son home what
ask her about sondheim who exactly your
son is he home which one
there's more than one
there are six
that's why make that seven i always
forget about paulie i can't remember
what this guy's name is jesus christ the
youngest i know it's like a circus name
i don't know if it's boring oh this is
marty it's not monkey boy he don't love
you no more two words so i can't
remember him
i can't i'm not too
any of them
are any of your children home
come in i'll make some tea
she's great
jesus christ
thank you missing we shot this
we shot two days
of 16-hour days
and i snorted coke friday and saturday
the [__] longest running show in
broadway history lloyd webb you know
what you see
you letting commercial success interfere
with your judgment of art i [__]
therefore something interfere with what
do you want me to interfere with flops
knock
what's this guy's name again
i'm not your mother now open the [__]
door
yeah yeah sure just just give me a
minute i'll be right there okay i still
bump into this guy twice a year maybe
once
what have we here joey
looks like an [__] sticking out a
window
hey butt like hey tony seen you here i
ain't [__] laughing oh my god he gets
stuck in the window i have no [__]
post the reason you haven't gotten back
to us you've been stuck in this window
for three months [__]
[__] no this is more of a recent
development shut up [__] turn this [__]
off okay
i'm dying right now that's so this is
the [__] you gotta do over the years to
to get big parts but no you're right so
like i would kill for this and that's
what like when you watch this when you
got this were you like thrilled out of
your mind
yeah you must have been like oh this is
gonna put me over the moon no i don't
remember i was a short film
at that point i had done a bunch of them
they got nowhere
also you were already this was the only
one that had
big people behind it
like fox was on the [__] set you know
there were agents on the [__] set
there were producers on the set because
they were still in the middle of
pitching into another network they
didn't know yeah they were gonna do this
short film
to get interest
and then take it from there
it got minimal interest
wow and it went away i was doing like
student films me too that's right
in the beginning you have to do 20 of
those [__] they were brutal they were
awful but no one was ever behind it
never fought nothing exciting problem is
that this is when it really started
wrestling i mean that's right you
wrestled for a while you were the mma
girls of [__] yeah i'll [__] fight
somebody right now but it was weird
because
you
attack it from different angles and you
don't see it at the time when
when nothing comes of it yeah but it all
added to your experience
right because yeah it wasn't it wasn't
happening the acting for me so i was
freaking out i kept getting engaged too
i think it was my second but with dice
when i was engaged to him we were at
least filming a reality show
so it felt like i was doing something
joining me but i wasn't like it wasn't
like a stellar acting job i mean i'm a
crazily trained actress that never got
any [__] work
because i think i was like too big into
the like i was jeff goldblum student at
playhouse west i studied under robert
carnegie i studied at a meisner cl i
went for two years me freddy soto corey
cuomo like we all went back what place
did you guys go to those tweezers jerry
sheppard yeah you couldn't audition for
two years
you weren't alone eisner it was in uh
santa monica it was the [__] d.w brown
and joanne parent are they still there
yeah
wow we didn't listen to them with the
audition and sherry sheppard got a movie
she didn't come in for she didn't
graduate until later she was in freddy's
class then freddy got a pilot he left so
he didn't graduate until later with me
and corey
but we were still auditioning we didn't
give a [__] we didn't listen to them
like you they tried to tell you that but
we were like nah [__] we're if we get
something we're going to [__] yeah
even oshak who oshak had the best if you
remember bob
yeah oh please great well he writes for
bill right uh great everything you they
used to want you to cry right like to to
reach your emotional so i could cry on
cue like i you know because i thought i
was gonna be meryl streep i was doing
plays and [__] nobody was watching but
but osha couldn't get to that emotional
level so he would go out in the hallway
and pluck his nuts
and try to get tears to come to his eyes
so i'd walk to the bathroom and i'd see
osha playing with his dick
but yeah he's that's how he would cry
that's how he graduated
no i know bruce nuts all those movies
those stupid little films i did i got
better every time i did one yeah that's
the only way to do what happens is like
i sit here sometimes i go like i
remember i did a student film after i
had already
been in big [__] films
and that's when you notice how much they
don't know what they're doing
yeah but in today's television world i
gotta be honest with you i'm gonna be
strictly honest with you
there's certain tv then
three or four people in the set know
what they're doing they're paying so bad
today
the pay is so bad on these movies
that the people don't know what they're
doing in the last 10 years you know how
many films i did
that i had to go back and redo the
[__] voice completely
because the tape was lost
in all those dog movies i did with dean
kane four of those movies the sound
they had to go back and because why they
cut dollars in the beginning of the
movie you get some [__] plumber to go
in there and tape your [__] movie and
then at the end it don't sound right now
you got to spend all that money again
and then some see they try to get what
you pay for you get what you [__] cut
and coin
absolutely i'll tell you why i did that
to make sure because
so many people
were not
paying not even a dime some people still
don't pay dawg i worked in films where
people have worked 30 days straight and
i got that's right and i've been there
from six to six they said they got an
hour before me and two after me for free
to get experience come on dog you got to
give me something yeah you gotta give me
your face at that point
abusive yeah it's abuse but people will
do it out here i think
you're not talking about that
yeah well like hearing you talk about
that ikea guy
the guy who directs all those uh videos
not the ikea guy
like the the more i've been out here the
more i think like that's the way to go
like industrial commercials like stuff
that you don't really need to maintain
well no like i'm talking about like like
i think what happens
in in especially like i've only had
production experience but these people
come out here and they actually like
want to be
filmmakers and they're artists
and you guys are artists you guys have
done
thousands of free sets but it's because
it's doing two because you love it and
they get you that way because you're
going to do it regardless you oh i'll
still work on the move it's it's good uh
whatever it's called it's
you but lee it's a complete different
story rather than seattle it was a woman
who did not like me right and she booked
independent one-nighters okay
like comedy shows yeah one night she had
30 of them okay she got mad at me over a
situation and she wouldn't book me
you know what i would do what i would
get a paid gig
but before my paid gig i see what time
it is so it's a 10 o'clock show i called
her i knew what
which one her gig started at eight
and i'd call her at the house and i go
how you doing i could tell that when
she'd answer the phone she'd go
because there was no caller id then yeah
so she would look at the phone and go
[__] yeah what can i do for you joey and
i go
can i go to the marine bar tonight and
do a guest spot
she couldn't say no to me it was a free
spot
you know she once told somebody joey
diaz is an [__] he does three guest
sets for free and i'm like [__] i'm in
l.a
yeah the reason why i'm in la is because
i did those three sets for free and it
made me stronger but remember you know
me i'm lazy
this was a 20 minutes there it was a 15
minute spot and 20 minutes home that's
an hour out of your day
i'll do that for anybody
i'll do that for anybody if you legit
would mean you go joey
i'm gonna shoot your scene after lunch
you're you're a professional joey
just show up at eight o'clock let's
shoot you the way greg garcia did that's
two episodes of [__]
my name is earlier greg called me a four
i so where you at i'm in the valley can
you get up to calabasas by 5 30. there's
a scene i want to put you in
there's no you know when i got there
they gave me a wardrobe they touched me
up there was no rehearsal they were
waiting for me there's that scene with
me and michael rappaport didn't you just
watch it yeah we shot that at four
o'clock come on up i got a scene for you
what are you doing here there was no
audition he just no no no no he hadn't
already given me that's great he had
already he he put up you trust that he
put me in like four or five episodes a
bunch the first two
he just these were scripted yeah the
next three were
what what else can i put in there
called joe diaz
i think you beat someone up once or
three yeah i hit him with a brick oh my
god he had me do a thousand things
that's great
see that's amazing that's a great person
too well that's when you're in your best
yeah
see i don't believe in beating up
anybody
i really don't lisa and i need you for
well he gets here four
we're gonna start at eight
oh that's brutal i wouldn't do that to
anybody because it's been done to me
yeah when it gets done to you you have
no [__] idea how you feel yeah
because while you're sitting there
you're like okay i'm gonna do this but i
could have been doing something else
yeah useful i could have helped my
mother i could have mowed the lawn i
could have gone shopping i could have
picked up the baby there's something i
could have done and now you have me here
like somebody was telling me they worked
with a headliner
a couple months ago and the gig was an
eight and the guy wanted to be there at
one
right he was like an hour away somewhere
like him and he told the guy i can't do
it and the guy's like well then you
can't go
because you got to drive me i want he
goes what are we gonna do
so he finally agreed he went up there
with the guy they got up there the guy's
like well i got one hotel room only
he goes so what are we going to do sit
in one hotel room and look at each other
there's people who do that to people
oh that's brutal there's people that do
whoever that is should be executed i
don't ever want to be [__] all right
well i can call you up and go lee
listen bro i'm in that situation
my [__] camera guy didn't show up
can't show up tomorrow
do me a favor man lee i can't give you
the right
right i can't give you your rate i'll
give you a buck 50 i'll give you a half
of
half a [__] ounce of weed and you're
my boy i mean how much work have i given
you over the years
that's one thing lee right but for me to
call you and go hey man
i need you for three weeks monday
through friday
eight to ten to work like a slave right
plus on my end there's no break you know
something like this there's people
trying to get away with breaks and sag
breaks you know how many times movies
i've worked on i've expected something
and the next thing you know i've gotten
like a thousand dollars more because
they never took a break
yeah and that's 45 hours of break oh
yeah they freak out that's a fine you
get fined what are you gonna like do you
get like a 15-minute break every hour no
no no no no no no no penalties yeah meal
plans
that's what they called okay so you
gotta eat six hours after you get there
yeah okay that's your first dinner break
if you're deep in a [__] scene you
have been breaking yeah they're like
[__] them all penalties
we'll pay it and they just by the man
too they [__] meal
i would get i auditioned for that
because they used wrestlers that were in
wow who i they came to watch us uh
wrestle so there was like four girls
they used i didn't know that yeah i
can't remember who they used they had
meal penalties when i did dickie
he does vicki roberts yeah oh
i got i got i don't know how many
thousands of meal penalties and they
didn't give them a [__] but i didn't
even notice meanwhile they got boxes of
food right so who gives a [__]
if you're gonna be joey you're done with
this scene for now you got 20 minutes to
your next scene [__]
i can put away a bagel locks
cream cheese
[__] cafelta fish a milkshake
i could put away stew some cookies a
piece of cake
and get back to the [__] set with a
chocolate chip stuck in my [__] tooth
i'll go on those sets and i will [__]
you up i don't need your [__] what
movie spider-man 2
they did not take meal penalties they
did not break for lunch
so they gave you an extra 35 hours a day
and you check
wow they would still break for an hour
lunch
yeah and you were supposed to eat
somewhere at sony
but what they would do is they still had
food out
yeah like if i talk about all this [__]
like when i worked on the boilermaker
that was probably my first hundred
dollar a day moving
wow well that is horrible for people who
come into la you're listening to me
going joey what did you do with
boilermaker then in 2007
it was the movie i stopped doing coke
for
because they [__] called me out
before i booked and said we know you're
[__] up
think about it tell us
but don't leave us there without decking
our hand that ain't good morning you
know a liability yeah so we really want
you for this but if you're gonna there's
gonna be a problem let's just move on
i was so embarrassed that i took the
[__] role
but that role was bottom dollar 100 a
day movie yeah for two or three years
that's all i did is that even a day
player what is that considered that's
not all right it's like a short extra
okay so what you have in sag
is scale yeah okay so scale is
let's say it's 6.95 a day okay okay
and then you have the next one down
that's
low budget uh
something low budget and that's 469 a
day okay and then they have a movie that
you get 249 a day
and then there's a hundred a day
and now there's ultra low budget no the
last couple years and that's 50 babins a
day what's that other word so for all
you people that are in college and
you're taking the mainstream you're
going enjoy what listen there it is
it's scale
it's 459
249 150
100 and then there's a 50 movie they
have now
i got just recently hit up about six
months ago three days would you do it
not in a million [__] years they
wanted me to be missing an arm like i
was a host with a missing arm and a
[__] uh
and a [__] what do you call those
things where old women go and play bingo
i got a church retirement home yeah but
i was like a dirty it was a fun and you
know what kills me cocoon with diaz
it was [__] hilarious
it's all these women would it have a
background on it or no no no no it's
50.50 that's it and they put you and
listen ladies and gentlemen you're
looking at me you're going joe you
wouldn't work for 15 hours [__] no this
principle and i'll tell you why this
principle guys now you're right because
when i got here everybody paid you
650 plus 10.
i'm not gonna lie to you there's a
couple of things i got a thousand
dollars a day for
there's a couple co-stars i got 950. i
got this high for co-stars maybe 17 15
12 17 50.
and then something and i got and i never
booked a guest though
when guest stars were paying
fifteen thousand you know how many of
those i booked none
then they became one day guest stars
and it's it's uh
those are the ones you want because they
have to pay you for two days so they
give you at least 1200 yeah
and all of a sudden
after 2000 in 2004
i in 2002 i shot my first
469.
the movie i did with rodney mm-hmm uh
back by midnight okay with with uh basil
as a director
that was 459 a day okay okay then what i
did for 259 was there's a scene in seven
where brad pitt walks up
to the crime scene and some guy gives
him a cup of coffee that's you that guy
no that's not me that guy
did a movie with his brother
and he put me in it and that was 249 a
day okay that was like in two
and then all the christmas movies i did
with dean kane for [__] abc family oh
okay they were all 100 a day
wow so i did five of them the first one
was 100 a day because if people see you
on tv they think you're rich yeah they
think you're rich and you're like no
[__] we made 100 no no and now
listen let's pretend
let me tell you something right now so
you make 650 a day
stop wrong six days 95 a day okay
let me put it to this way 10 of that
goes to your agent
and ten percent of that goes to your
manager so you're down 120 already so
from 690 you went to what 570.
now you got taxes and california taxes
oh okay you gotta take 30 28 on that 30.
30 on that
so there goes another [__] uh three
times that's 180. so already i got you
for [__] 180
120 that's 300
so look what you're gonna walk with
you're walking with 300 dollars to be on
television per day
if you get the whole week you walk with
fifteen hundred dollars do you work the
whole day
you work like a [__] slave you get
there at 7 30 in the morning and you
work till 10 o'clock at night yes they
give you overtime but you're on your
feet you're [__] getting yelled at
you're rehearsing your lines they
switched the script on you you stayed up
all night reading preparing to read a
[__] thing and you get to the next
day and they switch the whole thing on
you and you're the first scene up [__]
and guess what you hung over and you did
two grams of blow the night before your
memory is kabutz yeah and here you got
no it's [__] you're looking at the
lines and they're just blurry if you do
the 50 a day you actually i never did a
fifty the hundred dollar a day ones i
did ten of
okay because i enjoyed how did you make
any money you didn't pay okay so the no
i paid my ages at ten dollars a day oh
you pay them the ten dollars a day the
only movies hundred odd day movies i
made
any money on
were
uh the
santa ones okay the dog saved christmas
the dogs say because
after the first one you had they gave me
a back and they gave me at the moment
the movie was done yeah they handed me a
check for cash that nobody knew about
okay then the second one they did the
same i helped it
the third one the fourth one and so on
they upped it every movie from 500 to a
thousand dollars they were very good to
me
in that sense they're slave drivers
they had shitty food
the director was surprised they had food
he came to me one day and said not to
curse on the side to suck my dick he
never bothered me again yeah i farted
one time on this set and he asked me not
to do it no more what are you [__]
kidding me you got all this great foodie
i mean cream cheese with bagels
you're gonna fight eventually somewhere
if you watch the last thing if you
watched the last
two minutes of that first dean kane
movie i did
i got a little keys up i don't know what
they are i never watched it when the
movie ends
they have a bloop reel
like uh whatever you thought all the
mistakes yeah a blooper
yeah
and they go cut and also they go hold on
hold on
you hear a fart come on and dean's on
the bottom trying to push me off that's
real as [__] disco i was on top of
him
my stomach went in and i [__]
unleashed
the father death on that [__] dude
and that's how we became friends after
you become friends of course you have to
you don't want to
[Laughter]
who has no stories how does her life go
he has a pretty interesting story that
guy i bet he does you just is afraid to
tell it like maybe he's
you know he went to one of those he went
to a [__] one of those big time
schools i don't even know who he is
technically
he was superman he was superman yeah
again i don't know he went to what
school did he go to lee he went to a big
time school he dated that chick for a
while
he got drafted by the buffalo bills he
got put on the floor wait wait now
you're buffalo okay play four games ah
but if you talk to him you think he
would play in 18 super bowls and he
knows michael lauren but he's still a
great guy
and uh
but like when did he play back with oj
oh [__] he went to princeton yeah no no
he's the real deal who needs dayton
princeton come on at least jesus christ
you can't be that [__] mo motive oh
superman the tv that's the tv show i'm
sorry put a scene on put a scene on i
thought you meant the move i'm like what
a scene out for her for the dog to save
her brook shields he did the brook shoes
wow i was thinking toby mcguire is that
spiderman or superman i don't know
that's spider-man i don't pay any
attention to that [__] i live in the
real world not fantasy
yeah so no no he uh
and these were interesting i auditioned
for this i had to go to audition i had
to go to a call back
they made me sit there i came home the
first day and i'm like
[__] that was tough because they made me
go to the audition at 10
somewhere around here and the call back
was at 12.
and when i got there and it was maybe no
no i want you to put on the
not d kane superman put on uh
the dog that saved something joey diaz
the dog that saved christmas yeah same
christmas
and then put
joey diaz see what happens
look at that face you your buddies in
these too
your [__] buddies of these oh this
should be good
uh uh gary valentine oh i love gary
vayner god he was funny it's another
banister family christmas you are gonna
have so much fun here they have kidtopia
oh my god
oh i bet the toilet bowls in this place
are filled with fresh cold mountain
spring water but these two guys what
we're gonna do now have their sights set
on ruining this family vacation wait
about five more minutes hey they stole
my necklace i'll walk in that store you
buy a 250 000 necklace for five bucks
hey zeus look at this honey that looks
very expensive five bucks they're all
the same what are the banisters doing
here what are we gonna do now we would
like to rent the honeymoon suite we're
finally gonna be able to get revenge on
that mangy mud that made us spend last
christmas behind bars this year hey kids
give your granny some love hey zacky
apollo right it's zeus look at his face
see they're cutting back on the dog
like the dog voice was always terrible
so these guys made money
i love it what are they doing with our
necklace how are we going to get it i
got a plan we should get a plan last
time
[Music]
vacation how bad is it
did you drink out of a wet bowl when
you're a puppy
stars presents it's that dog the doggone
sequel to the canine family event how
many thoughts
up here
oh
that is amazing all of these
i think i mean you got great tapes out
of this though like in my head i'm like
i i was in dice twice and got cut out
both times
that's cold-blooded cold [__] blooded
i don't know why it's it's scott
armstrong he's terrific right the show
runner however he's used to doing movies
so i the two episodes i was in were the
ones he directed and he he loves my
stuff like he's oh like the first year
when they caught me he's like i'm so
sorry but the thing is is he writes it's
supposed to be a half hour he'll write
it like it's a [__] movie and then we
have all this great stuff and then he's
got to cut it like i watched the episode
i got cut out i was playing milkshake's
sister at a bar mitzvah
and the thing went so fast i'm like i
don't even know where they would have
put my scene like
because it's a half hour it would have
been a
i don't know an 80 minute show at that
point like with all the other scenes
because i also did some punch-up writing
for it so that was that some of that
stayed in there natasha got me that job
actually
natasha uh she was like can you get
eleanor to punch this up because
it's got to be a little funnier it's got
to move faster which is very compliment
very nice so i did get that work but the
i got cut out of my bar mitzvah scene
again it's all experienced i mean i got
paid now you know how to not get cut out
next time you got to [__] make it
happen
i don't they're mic you gotta rock them
but it was so funny the scene between me
and andrew it was just too many
like there was also a lot of funny
scenes with andrew and this rabbi it was
a kind of uh this is your life
or a wonderful life remember that show
jimmy stewart yeah so that's what they
did to andrew and this rabbi is like
yelling at him at a bar mitzvah
just saying like
what you know if andrew dice clay had
never been born and then it goes to him
being like a regular schmoe
he's in a nightmare
so
i'm telling you if you watch it it's
great
but even when we were filming it i
thought
how the hell we filmed so much how are
they going to narrow this down to 30
minutes
like even last year i got cut out for
adrienne brody because they filmed so
many great scenes with adrien brody that
adrian was like make you know scott
armstrong said well we're going to make
it uh it can only be a half hour and
adrian was like screw it make it a
double episode do it and make it an hour
and scott's like i can't do that i only
have a half hour but then why shoot all
this [__] but that's because that's just
his mindset it's just how he does and
he's terrific like he's they did old
school he did hangover you know he's a
brilliant guy it's not like you know he
don't know what the [__] he's doing he's
and he puts all these great directors
too like if he's not directing he has
cos um
todd biermann that does uh it's always
sunny in philadelphia and jake harris
who directs a lot of specials he did
bill birth
i think last two or three
and he's been directing a lot of comedy
specials now but he also does a ton of
tv
so
the show is really funny i just i'm like
whatever i got cut out listen man
i think i've been cut out of one thing
i'm pissed but
i should have been cut out of 15 things
yep shut up i never forget when i shot
basketball
i don't fresh out the store
okay i just got to the store i just got
the lay
i got a [__] manager
i got a black
the agent was called the coloring book
they were on the water brothers
and the [__] paper that you used for
your resume how to be different colors
so it cost me 10 or 20 hours more a
month just to be with them because i had
to put a staple headshots on your resume
and it had a different color i had to go
to ming ming [__] copy there what's
his name on the sunset across my guitar
center oh my god the chinese dude
there everybody's gonna that's where you
went to get uh
mr ming printing his little chinese dude
when he went away i went to the other
guy on sunset and the little uh across
from now whatever that i don't even go
there anymore but it's a different world
though yeah the printing world right
headshot
now yeah
it's [__] god
remember j j beep is gone huge they had
the whole floor that [__] mall he was
involved with that chick he went to jail
yeah
what happened mr ming mr ming was on on
sunset did anyone check in on it across
from mom mr mingle i drove by the other
day i said felice and my heart stopped
because i felt so bad but he hasn't been
there for a while no he's been there he
was there no he's shiny he's there
six days a week because i didn't see i i
guarantee you well i guess that wasn't
gonna be your resume business went out
of business yeah because the headshot
business no because now
you [__] you have a printer at the
house
and the headshots are done
people go buy head shots they're dirt
cheap now
dirt cheap they'll give them to you just
to keep the little [__] dude alive um
lebron hollywood behind always walk i've
been going there for [__] 20 years
that's right
every time i go in there they have
everything because they do great retail
yeah they have every [__] headshot i
ever did
yeah i did all mine there too
nicest people in the world see their
packages next to a bagel place so i
would go in and get a bagel get the head
shot down the corner they had a cigar
shop and the cigar shop was behind
wendy's so you don't lose it that more
upstairs is a karate school
they got everything at that mall and
somebody yelled at me for going there
they're like it's too expensive and i'm
like it's it's right there it's right
there it's right [__] there you don't
have to drive around so good they were
good except for one time they made me
look like rocky raccoon because they
were trying to fix my eyes i'm like dude
that's my eyes i look like marty feldman
just [__] leaving i never [__] did
retouch photos
they would tell me all the time they
were telling me all the time take that
pimple out of there leave it there that
pimples character [__] it shows that i
lived a lot work and i didn't because i
didn't [__] idiot i never
since day one they would tell you okay
hi we're going to sign you but this is
what we need for you to do you need to
go on cast net and put your picture i
tell them from the beginning listen
we love your look this is no disrespect
but you need to do a headshot and i go
listen here it is
you get that headshot right there let's
put it to work
and once we make a few the bookings i
get no headshots you think i'm kenyan
and they were looking at me like well
for right now for today just to get the
ball started
let's send some new headshots and let's
just get that i promise you let's get
the first job i get new headshots i'm
like that i never get a new headshot i
signed with an agent that called me into
office and they said listen you usually
book a plumber construction
a mafia
she gave me five
[__] it she goes i want you to get a
head shot for each one and i want you to
go to this photographer i called the guy
he wanted 250 for each head shot back
and take a listen i called it back i
said listen out of the six take your
pick
i think we go with the mobster you
wanted six 250 per person oh lee you
have no idea
this is rip off city
and that's cheap now now it's 800. yeah
somebody told me they paid 800 for head
shots recently what no that's crazy i
did a shoot with uh the guy who shoots
at the store he was terrific
troy comrades i couldn't for a second i
was going to call him dude
and you know what he does he does a lot
of like um digital stuff for you so like
if you have a show coming up that like
he'll
he does like stuff you can use to put
your dates next to your picture don't i
mean like social media [__] that you
could use for all of it he takes great
pictures he does he's amazing he's
really really good at this if you ever
have the store go check out his his
not that expensive yeah oh yeah he does
the hallway series yeah the hallways
here is just still up but even if you
want regular headshots he took regular
headshots for me then he said look i'm
going to give you some social media
stuff so like if your shows or stuff new
year's day we even did like write your
thing over it exactly we even did like i
think i wore a hot uh gold dress like he
was like in case you're doing a show on
new year's eve or you just want to say
i'm being classy whatever like different
kind of variations but fun stuff for
social media and regular headshots and
he was not that expensive and he touched
them up and i think i did it last
december i called him two weeks ago i
was like hey can you help me out my
commercial agent needs this this he goes
i'll send it in the next couple hours
any day he was right on it he's great
it's one of my favorite people troy
comrade yeah that's a lot of fun but
yeah don't hey man listen when you go to
an agent they give you a sheet of paper
yes i got one from my commercial agent i
go no i already have headshots and they
go please use one of these people
because they get a taste of that lee
[__] yeah
okay they want those people [__]
no i was over it from day one i never
bought into it when i got here another
thing i keep repeating the cast net
okay so
the process is this you give your
[__] agent
200 headshots
and when a row comes out for you she
takes that head shot with a cover letter
and she licks the envelope and sends it
in right that's what people do that are
failures
okay if you want to be a failure as an
agent
that's what you do
what this agent would do this black lady
she used to say listen there's a role
for you
that we can't pass on
i'm gonna call this [__] right
now i'm gonna put a head shot right now
to get carry it over to him
but he goes for lunch at 1 30. i want
you to have one at 2 30 when he gets
there and give him another head shot so
he'll call you in and it worked every
time
and i believe in that that's why i
started doing that stay on top of no if
you see something you want go down there
go down it
see today it's not as liberal today
after 9 11 they closed the studios down
at you yeah in the old days you know
larchmont yeah largemouth that first two
blocks
those are the big casting people in town
they call you over the largemouth you're
going places you got the place on uh
across from the
what's the [__]
the grove yeah there's a place i live
right there all right there's a place
grocery from the grove
if you're going down the street on
location
right across this little building nobody
knows about it that guy cast
i think you're right i think i have
bread in there i think i remember cast
everything they offer you water white
people
there's a couple of offices they offer
you white water they offer you water
validation those are white people then
you're going to be savages you know
gower oh yeah
yeah
cylical those people are savages
they hope you get a [__] they hope you
get towed yeah they got no class [__]
hate they're you know when you go to
paramount they make you park all the way
at the end yeah no don't drive off no no
no drive on they [__] torment you you
get there all sweaty these places are
high level when you go into the lake
what's that steven spielberg movie he
did about four no
he did about eight years ago i was dying
to get it
listen i tried to get the animation yeah
and i was playing like a half a gangster
and i went to the producer's session and
i looked down
and it's three guys me steve sharipa
and some other [__] dude right
that i don't know i look at the guy's
headshot i go it's between me and steve
schripp i ain't getting this
i picked my head up i said i'm gonna get
this i went in there read my [__]
heart out for this
it was 60 days of shooting
with a body suit on whoa so they had to
shoot you with the body suit on them
with the body shoes shoot off
big money
big money it was some [__] stupid
animated show that didn't work there's
the beauty of it oh animation i cried
like a [__] okay rin tintin oh there
you go
that little guts
it did dick it made three dollars and
they gave you your money back when you
walked out
i cried like a little girl when i didn't
get that movie when they called me and
said we went with another i get it i go
[__] sharipa and a week later i went
on mdb and it wasn't sheriff i wonder
what it was it was some kid you never
saw before
i never saw this [__] kid before i
mean i wasn't even that broken heart
like what am i gonna do it's brutal and
i'm glad like i'm learning now to not
give a [__] but before i was so nervous
because when i started taking like just
say acting classes i was going to temple
university in philadelphia so i go to
temple everybody else was came from
money families they had like you know
their family was paying their tuition i
was hustling to get the money to pay to
go to to school you know so i'm sitting
there in a fee law suit reading
shakespeare and they're just [__]
laughing at me so i always felt out of
place
so i would get nervous like oh i have to
i have to look more like this or they
were like oh you have to take american
standard english because no one know
your accent is so bad
that no one can understand you we can't
have you do shakespeare we we don't even
know what you're saying and and he don't
speak well so you're really [__] so i
then they put me in this american
standard english class so i'm learning
how to say things but at the same time
i'm life guarding in south philly at a
public pool so i'm using i'm learning
using my
language i'm learning i'm like get out
of the water and they're like the [__]
is wrong with you it's water jerk off
and i'm like
oh [__] so i was always like confused
like [__] i'm trying to fit in i'm not
so there was a long time there where i
felt like i lost myself like i was just
trying to
do the right thing like
i guess be like everybody else instead
of be who i am which is not definitely
not like everybody else much like you
like
we're just a [__] outcast when i
first got here we're not we don't fit
into everybody's mold i got him on
monday
i got him i got him on monday night i
went to the comedy store yeah uh
i knew james steve was deterred and he
talked [__] uh what's his name i love
paul miller to go on stage no james
stevens i know but monia called them
james stevens the turd and i went up
there because what's his name was
hosting late night on mondays
and he put me up there tuesday i went to
the lab factory and wednesday doug
stanhope gets a call i'm staying with he
goes hey judy brown
is casting uh
some [__] tv oh jenny mccarthy's show
yeah her name again
and terry's doing it
and they need a limo driver for him for
a scene
and i went down there
and everybody was like joey just be
yourself
and like okay so let me do go in there
tie him up and rob him
like i didn't have no [__] idea
what the [__] people were talking about
be yourself i don't even know who the
[__] i am
i'm embarrassed just to walk into this
audition and i went in there and they
looked at me lee like
oh this kid's terrible
they were like thank you for coming in
i'm like
that's how i got well no no they throw
you into weird situations here in the
beginning but that's how you learn
anything in this life
you're not going to learn something
you know i haven't been going into
audition
where your [__] hand with shay
at the sopranos producer session
summer of 90 summer of 2000 i was here
three years
i was auditioning because i had a great
manager i had jeff gallon oh yeah i
forgot about him i'll never forget going
into the surprise and reading
but you had to hear this
try listening to an audition
when your hand is shaking like a [__]
fan that you know you're not going to
get the role
it's already on i would but the thing
was i did good reads i knew i memorized
everything i'm good at memorizing front
to back for those type of auditions i
stay up for days i write everything out
the pause is exactly how i'm gonna do it
i walk into the room i practice the walk
i do the whole [__] thing but that's
all you heard throughout the whole
audition is my hand shaking from my
nerves
that took years to get rid of
like that took those because i went from
reading short films
to reading
men in black i went in for them and i
[__] my pants
good auditions i never got any of those
that's amazing but when i saw it with
jeff gellman yeah he was great i
remember i was going to advance for
acting i went to her i studied and uh
she was making women show their
attendees and their businesses oh yeah
[__] which was always great thursday
night late class you had to show that
[__] and you gotta let a guy like me
get on top of you make out with you
every class very strong it was very
strange but that's why all those women
she had two women that won academy
awards why because he made the women
go out of themselves
eleanor would never kiss me but at that
school we had to do a scene where
eleanor would have to be nude and i'd be
nude with my leg over
and you have to just focus on not
getting a hard on
like i did one love scene there
i don't think i'd be able to i think i
failed i couldn't handle it
it was pretty brutal i didn't have a
dick scene but i was with her and my you
know you have to focus on your dick not
getting over it yeah my favorite was the
meeting with her
i had a father i had a yeah yeah yeah
you had to meet with her and i got
recommended by william morris but at the
time it was my fiancee billy who was
running the comedy department so he said
he goes oh go to ivana so i go meet with
her she goes oh william morris who are
you with over there like well i'm not
signed with william morris they just i
have a friend there they recommend well
i don't understand how you would get in
my presence
if you're not with william morris like
who sent you here and i go i'm [__]
the head of the comedy division is that
work for you
and she went yeah it does come on in and
we became best friends like it was
because i was like don't grill me [__]
somebody gave me your number like i'm
not
i'm trying but i i was
got angry and then she loved me from
that moment on and then i had a great
time in her class i was there for about
six months
and i learned a lot i learned about
acting
but i also learned who i was going up
against
and it was so weird that
i was going i thought
i was in uncharted territory this is why
people you have to
go for what you believe in because
when i was in those acting class in the
beginning i walked in there and didn't
say a [__] word
okay i didn't say a word now the first
time i walked into an acting class
was when i got here let me tell you
about this story about the first acting
class
you ever go on sunset and gardener
yeah you know what toy is yeah it's like
okay on the same side of toy if you make
a a right there if you make a left on
that toy side mm-hmm on gardiner
before you hit the burger place uh
sunset grill oh yeah sunset girl if you
could stand up 30 yards there's a little
school there okay the guy's name was
frank something
and he had a pretty good acting class it
was a hundred a month monday nights
seven to ten he hated because mondays at
that time when i got here was the
hottest night in hollywood you had the
black knight at the improv and yeah it's
latino night yeah at the left factory
yeah the store had the open mic which
you could still do a triple header which
i did that's what i used to go for
triple headers if you got a seven minute
spot at the end probably a 20 minute
spot at the laugh factory and then you
closed it out with the store [__] yeah
you went home talking [__] that hey
so he
it was weird i was with him
buyer
oh that's a good one that's a good one i
had two salads today
why do you fan it on yourself you're
just like my brother
what kind of salad
uh i had a burger i have marie tea and
they make your garden celery cucumbers
oh nice nice light dressing oh yeah and
then tonight
and then tonight my wife made a little
uh chilean bass
and she made a little kale salad with
egg
i'll let her know it smells good on the
way out as well i was eating that egg i
knew i was gonna have a problem with the
podcast tonight when you put hard-boiled
egg into anything your asshole's on fire
so i'm in there about to sit through it
i'm i'm just not breathing through my
nose when i went in there the first time
i didn't say [__] i was
i can't lie to you people i was just a
little place on gardner there's a little
place on gardner
i was probably here six months
i was awkward i was very scared i was
intimidated and i went into his acting
class and god bless him
he let me watch the first week
then the second week
i was supposed to go up but the class
didn't have enough time
and then i was gonna go up second the
third week
and dog that was one of the hardest
things i ever did was go up and i knew
nothing about that [__]
i thought i was going to go in there
they were going to teach me how to
[__] act i didn't know you had to do
scenes
i knew nothing about scenes
yeah nothing and
he taught me blah blah blah and all of a
sudden he goes listen i'm gonna put you
up
every monday at 8 45 she can get out of
here and do comedy
so four weeks in a row he did that
in one scene a girl goes
he goes anybody have recommendations for
a scene for joey diaz
there's a true story he'll unlock and
some guy goes
why don't you give him a ford fair lane
he kind of reminds me of dice
and he knows he goes halt stop the class
he goes i want you to do me a favor
people i don't care what you do in this
class as long as you don't drink a guy
and come to my class
but i have a third rule
never meant to andrew dice clan in this
class ever again why
so about two weeks later i stopped
getting auditions
big auditions
and i called one day for a private
and then i called them again they were
like forty dollars in those days twenty
five dollars thirty dollars
and then the second private you know we
were talking about new york and pizza
and where he was from and blah blah blah
and he told me he was from brooklyn and
i i go let me get in there right now
they go so that's how you know dice from
brooklyn the old days and he goes i
thought i told you people not to mention
nice i go listen man
i'm just curious i see him at the store
and i want to know the animal i'm
dealing with yeah and this [__]
twisted the chair and sat down and he's
like let me tell you a little story oh
my god i knew andrew before this and
this and
met can i know his wife dee dee whatever
her [__] name was
but he had two there was the first the
very first one oh no she she's two she's
number two what's her name uh trini
training and the whole thing
and then he's talking all this [__] he
goes and andrew at the end bailed on me
and he went with two other writers after
we worked hard and stuff like that
he goes the beauty of it is he never
called me frank perna his wife died
his wife died him and his wife taught
the class they were very nice people
and his wife died like a year after i
quit he was kind of mad at me for
quitting i just told him the truth like
oh monday's a hot night bro
and i ran out of chocolate and i met an
advantage only back had tuesday mornings
ah at ten o'clock i would go from ten to
eleven thirty one o'clock
you know then after a while yeah i would
go 10 in the morning and stay tuned one
i would do the whole [__] thing and
then they tried to promote me to
thursday nights and i went and ordered
it one time and i'm like listen let's be
honest
i could sit there with all those pretty
[__] [__] i'm trying to do
scenes naked and [__] with all these hot
chicks or i can make money because
thursday nights in l.a
is a hot night it's at least a 15 bill
somewhere yeah somewhere in l.a if
you're a hustling comic there's a 30 or
50 dollar bill waiting for you somewhere
never mind the store or the live factory
or the improv that fart was tremendous
wasn't it
it really stayed in the airplane it did
it that egg
that egg is just drifting lee where's
the [__] tony bennett
i think he might have i think he might
have smelled that fart
it's funny to watch all those
[__] shorts and [__] that we watch
it's amazing
what a history
no i always wanted
to be covered
i saw at that time even then i saw a lot
of comments
that had were tremendous comedians
but you got to assume at that time i
knew no i'm not i'm not i'm lying to you
people i'm really lying to you people i
knew how the game worked but i really
didn't
but i always knew one thing that at one
point you didn't want to travel no more
as much
and you always wanted to have television
to fall back on
and now or something that keeps you in
town in a spot
it's really nice like i told people a
thousand times especially
really nice to drive cbs radford five
days away yeah four days a week for
wardrobe they got great catering it's in
the valley you know i bumped into a
thousand people there from al madrigal
to [__] people shooting next to you
uh or you could keep carrying your
luggage to
wherever every weekend put your t-shirts
with them i always thought that the
resume and the guy who inspired me the
most
to get my acting chops up was andrew
i had an interesting conversation with
him behind the thing when he
was working rascals
he was telling me a story they got a
call from michael mann
to audition to do crime stories do crime
story and he went down there
and he and this is the [__] pilot i
mean andrew shot the [__] pilot jack
he said he went down there like in march
and he read he knocked out of the park
and he goes i booked the road because
in between takes i kept going that's
what the director's really looking at
so i always remembered that when i went
to an audition he goes that's what he's
really looking at is what you're doing
between takes when the casting people
are giving you direction
they want to see how you react to the
direction that's probably audition tape
so i'll never forget that so whenever
he said that he got that
tv show
because he did everything backwards
he does everything back and everything
backwards because he didn't want to be
like everybody else
he goes well i'd be like he goes yeah
we're going to audition everybody's
doing the same thing outside read it
backwards that's why when i go to
audition i go early and i listen to the
first three guys before me
if they all sound the same i switch i
got an audible i'm calling
right in the [__] room i call an
audible and they're like oh [__]
this [__] got it
even if we take him to the producers he
may not get it but just the ability that
he had to change it up
to show something different yeah to
stand out because that's important
you know we're talking about alan
stevens
when i read for alan stevens had to be
2003. by that time i was getting started
to get good at auditions but i was bad
at one audition are you ready mm-hmm the
one-liner
oh like if there was one line oh my
[__] god ladies and gentlemen if
you're thinking about acting
there's a thing called the one-liner in
a tv movie
under five
under five no no no no no
there's under five and then there's when
you have a tv show and you have one line
whose phone is that ringing right
you know
that type of [__] yeah those are the
ones
those are the worst auditions in the
world
when you have to go into a room in front
of three people
and go
whose phone is that
i was going into these auditions one
after the other after the other i would
go for four auditions in one week and
every week for a year and a half
i had a [__] one-liner
oh who sent you all those things like
one-liner mobster movie
you know i mean [__] he was endless
there was a parade of one letters and i
didn't know what to do one day on my way
to arless
i was going to read for lisa dowd or
something this i got my memories out of
the way there
as i was walking i go oh [__]
what the [__] is wrong with me how
stupid am i
turn the one line into three
ah
[Music]
because you go in let's say on the sheet
of paper
it says mom what's for dinner there you
go okay that's the line on the sheet of
paper you're actually going to go in
there and
you're actually going to go in there
you're going to [__] what's that when
you set when you tell your name yeah
whatever you're slate hi my name is joey
diaz i'm reading for [__] dice clay
okay you ready
ma what's for dinner oh my god that was
great
that was great you want me to do it
again no no no that was great thank you
are you available in the 15th yeah they
do that just to bust your balls you
weren't great
any [__] [__] could have gone into
that room and said that
the thing is yoma action what are we
action
ma
what's for dinner
yeah you just took
ten seconds you just added beats to it
yeah and turned it into 45 seconds
i can't believe i'm an acting class on
monday night it was yes i'm loving this
[__] amazing
once that came to me i would have i
wanted one of that if you watch it you
look at the imdb of me there's a bunch
of the bottom half you count those in
half those are all co-stars and all
those co-stars were in one line
all of them i did what was the show i
did with the hot chick that was on abc
she played a detective for a while her
father was the guy from esposito no no
she was an uh american gangster she was
very good at the american gangster she
played the white dude's wife the ira the
australian guy's wife at the park
oh her accent was good
she had a show one line i had that
uh law and order one line
i mean i just booked one line
moving that was amazing then there was a
streak i went on that was the beginning
of every movie wasn't spiderman a
one-liner sure was
in the subway and by that time i was
good at one-liners by the time i went
into one that one
i sat at home i scratched my head
i said i'm a guy on the train in new
york what am i supposed to look like
so i would enable a white t-shirt and a
yankee head
as tacky as i could be as they wanted
you to be that's right i was fat as [__]
and on the way there i stopped somewhere
and i got like a fake newspaper and put
it under my arm
so i'm supposed to be on the train he
comes through i get to this audition
paulie walnuts just left
like they were there early yeah like
they had a bunch of new yorkers there
early i was there with the guy from
that movie with clooney and brad pitt
where they robbed the hotel
i was in there with a bunch of dudes i
had booked a bunch of [__]
this lady that booked this book the
the richard gear movie with the hot
chick
the one that he became a [__]
gangster over and the chick
the one about the [__] hooker that he
falls in love with the whole halfway
pretty woman pretty woman pretty woman
she booked nine and a half weeks
so i was petrified already going there
you had a park in the sony parking lot
and walked to the end of hell
and it was july i know i read for it
like one of those hot days in [__]
march
one of those days and march returns 90.
yeah you're like you go out you go out
thinking it's gonna be 50.
so i had the white shirt on with the
yankee hat and i had a velour
black big daddy
sweatshirt on that weighed 20 pounds i
walked across that lot with that [__]
thing on
i thought i was gonna die i get to the
audition i look at the call sheet
as all those people's names and i'm
looking around the room guys
between you and me there's 30 gorillas
in there all
from new york
i got depressed i look down and i go
okay
i went and little by little i slipped
closer to the door
and i listened to everybody action
if you want to get the hell you're going
to get through me
cut thank you action you're going to get
the higher you're going to get to me
i'll listen to 10 of them and right
there i figured it out i'm going to go
in there rip this room apart as i walked
in
i said hello to her and her assistant
and the producer
but as i walked in i saw i walked in
towards them and they were on my right
but on my left there was a couch
i forced them to slay me in front of the
couch
okay
i go what do you want me to stand they
go right there but i let it go and i
went under the light by the couch
the couch was behind me okay
didn't even see it coming
you don't even see it coming i'm excited
and i said this is spider-man 2.
take a look at my face i got holes in it
i'm on coke
the only way i'm gonna [__] do this
if i make them remember me yeah
i'm 360 pounds at the time
i've been up for two days and with all
this [__] on my mind i thought of this
and she goes action
and i wasn't even looking at them i look
over at the camera
and i took a pause and i swallowed like
the fat dude and the chinese connection
there's a scene where a fat dude looks
over at bruce lee and he sees that he's
bruce then he goes
and he swallows like a nervous like a
nervous tit
i swallowed and i go
you want to get to him you got to go
through me
with a little dot on my face and all of
a sudden he's supposed to hit me with
the tail i flew backwards
landed on the couch 360 pounds the couch
tipped over i tipped over my hat fell
off they both came over and helped me up
what do you think got that wrong though
i saw the movie you see what i'm saying
i didn't get that role because i was
better than everybody i saw that couch
you made them think this is my
opportunity to jump backwards like that
whip yeah in the sides and it was one of
those auditions doing that you didn't
know what was that that you got there
yeah they gave you signs with your name
on them that were blueprinted so you
couldn't take them yeah nobody was
allowed then nobody was allowed to have
them
same with the wrestlers i don't think
the girls i didn't we wouldn't have
signs we just had to walk around the
cage remember when they were having a
cage it's crazy lee in those days
men in black
you had to get the audition there read
it and give the lion the sheep back on
the way out because everybody was
stealing no camera you couldn't take
pictures of the [__] sheets
hilariously and now look they have
entire seasons of game of thrones
getting leaked
how they do it on purpose
everybody leaks on purpose they're a
bunch of lies
like i mysteriously got leaked
somebody leaked my naked phone
how do they know who's got naked phones
guys i have naked photos on the internet
i want you to all look it up
are they out there i'm kidding
people would be like what the [__]
i'm just trying to give people something
to do
you know leo is funny that
even with casting i'll put some we were
talking about breakdowns
a couple weeks ago how breakdowns are
what people look for
when you want to be in a movie or
something they say i'm going to break
downs to see what's in there today to
see if you're in there
the problem we get in the breakdowns is
you see the real nitty gritty yeah and
you know just like in the world of
whatever i'm joe diaz has a company he
sells medical equipment on the phone
base salaries thousand dollars plus
commissions and incentives and you get a
rental car and then you got a car
lisa act comes in
he's one of a hundred [__] applicants
you know
what lee doesn't know is my company we
made it we cut a deal
because my brother's a [__] [__]
he cut a deal with some people that for
the first three years
before we hire somebody they got to
screen them they're charging us 30 000 a
year for a service we could have done
ourselves
okay so that's what most people do not
know yeah that they have an hnr
department that i could give
recommendations to
but they do the final thing okay okay
let me explain something to you
who gets hired all the time in today's
america family
yeah family okay friends so yeah lisa
that's a great [__] family guy
let me tell you something
i got a kid out of college he's my face
my god son he needs a job bad
that's what lee doesn't know and he'll
do it for
no 30 000 left he won't do it for 30 000
no he's going to get more he's going to
get more than that uh that's how that
works it happens
that's how that works sometimes the most
incompetent make the most money no i
agree with the show you'll see over the
years listen you'll see over the years
my nephew just got drafted to the
minnesota twins oh [__] right so he's in
their farm system he's playing a single
a but he didn't get drafted out of
college
because they hire family
that you know and the people that they
got one kid that got drafted like the
puerto rican kid that he played on vcu
he was a shortstop he was [__]
awesome he didn't get drafted
they him and jimmy were like the two
best they didn't get drafted so they're
like who the hell are they drafting they
look it up it's like family members one
kid got drafted to the chicago and then
he got hurt he didn't play the whole
year but he still got like you know 100
grand or whatever it was for a signing
bonus to get to the it's like what what
is this so he had a play in a minor
league ball club
then
boosts his stats up that way and then a
scout saw him and then they put him on
the twins so now he's in this
system
but it's just like
they only hire family and they pay them
out the wazoo family and friends i don't
know more about sports i mean but i'm
saying it happens now it's everywhere
now like i know in the corporate world
we really don't know who we're going up
against yeah so that's why when you
apply for a job and you do a really good
interview and you go for the second
interview and you don't get that
position
you never know what else is going on
yeah the same thing happens with acting
yep if you're a blonde and you're going
in for that role
let me tell you something that director
is [__] blind on the side she's
getting that role no matter if you go in
there and you cry on the spot yeah
doesn't matter if you can make smoke go
out of your ass it doesn't matter and i
can't yeah and they don't care it
doesn't matter
all that [__] doesn't matter because at
the end they're looking out for a friend
like we all do in this [__] life we
all look out for that friend listen put
him in there it's a day's work yeah you
know that's why in the beginning people
really liked me so nine out of ten it
wasn't the role i was going in for
but they felt so bad that they made me
go for the call back that they would
give me anna ferris
oh i love her she did that movie about
smoking weed what's that movie she did
about getting high all day
good question i don't know look at how
imdb i love anna ferris she's so funny i
got to make her laugh in the o.r once in
there was this japanese director that
did something big
and he had all this heat on him
and one day
anna ferris is doing a movie about
stoners
and she
hires this director this
director like everybody's that i read
for was like everybody i told i was
reading for this or like dawg
you have no idea how badass that
director is blah blah blah blah blah
he made me go in there three or four
[__] times man
for two different roles that's how much
he dug me and i didn't get both of them
and like a
smiley face smiley face oh so is that a
real thing i mean that's a real that's a
real movie yeah that's fun and it's anna
ferris anna ferris and like a week
before christmas i got a call
joey we're really sorry but
can you come in for three hours we'll
give you a scale you're a security guard
that chases her
thank you for being a sport and coming
into those four times
we really loved you but the producers
went a certain way but i got a day for
you
there's a lot of people who do that yeah
because they know you actually stayed up
and you struggled that yeah and you're
yeah but every audition i got i could
tell you a trick i did that nobody else
figured out i didn't go in there and do
what everybody else did i refused that's
that's the thing i let myself go in
there you know before we started the
podcast today we're talking about
statuses
and lee was talking about like a ufc
fighter like
do people think of later
i always thought him later here
i didn't want to be that see i didn't
know
i didn't think that at the age of 50 i'd
be on the road i thought at the age of
50 between you and i honest engine that
you would be i thought i would be
finishing up a tv show and about to get
syndication money that's what i really
thought was it a big role no no no no
i'm talking about i was a plumber i did
six episodes a season that's the funny
plumber i bent over you saw the crack in
my ass you clapped
i walked off stage i sold some tickets
for a couple weeks until they found out
i was a [__] pig
and we all moved on that's what i
thought the outcome was gonna be
all right i didn't know i was gonna be
[__] cracking jokes
right right but i also knew that
just in case i wanted to have an acting
resume
because i didn't want to wake up one day
when you're 50 with one [__] movie
that you got yeah because your friend
put you in it but besides that
you know
you come here you become a stand-up
but you gotta remember all our [__]
idols did [__] movies
i hate when most comics go well this
guy's a sellout or whatever from richard
pryor to [__] you know
and then jackie gleason they all did
movies that was the final
step of this journey yeah to do this as
a [__] artist so that's what you want
to consider yourself as a [__] artist
you got new movies short films long
films some theater i saw a dude the
other day that i got fired with i got
fired from the theater production he was
the worst
it was the worst piece of [__] of all
time this would be in korean a ton of
theater oh my god theater in l.a is
brutal it's just like signing a death
warrant
that i toured with
in [__] theater acting in l.a it is
so badly
that's how dumb i was know when history
goes
i tried to get to three different acting
troops i was one of those [__] first
part of gary marshall's [__] theater
yeah no no no
dick i was part of i o for a while yeah
yeah then i realized all those kids were
just rich kids that [__] were
confused i wouldn't write on that line
let me go to l.a and also after three
years that dad's like listen [__]
yeah come back and sell staples for me
sell staples well i didn't have that i
couldn't go home no work at the
typewriter store [__] do you think i
haven't been better off here did you
really think
bro
my b plan was to sell blow
i was gonna marry the mob i mean i could
still do it because they'll be on their
like third divorce now so i could sneak
in there right the mob is done yeah but
i'm just saying these jackals that still
live in my neighborhood they call
themselves no these poor guys it's just
weird that there was i had an offer in
atlantic city last week a guy said come
on i'll take care of you
all right i said i asked my brother my
brother jimmy was there so i go ask
jimmy because he knew him if i could go
out with you and then he went over to
jimmy and jimmy he goes
is she really single and jimmy's like
yeah she's single why would she lie
about that and then the guy goes well
can i date her and jimmy's like you're
too short get the [__] out of here like
just [__] all over them
and the guy was like really
he was about 5-1
with a lot of confidence a lot
that's what you all leave five minutes
i'm five three
good five four maybe a good day
good confidence i'm pretty i don't know
although i'm kind of goonish so
i just have a little high
and then i wear heels because i'm a dick
like i'll wear wedges just to piss on
you you know what i mean lee
you probably could piss on me
so all together how many years acting
class do you think we're under your belt
oh man
all together fauna
irish klein i don't i mean i was
everywhere yeah of course
three years at playhouse west two years
at
uh joann baron d w brown i went to
temple i studied with steven stahl
philadelphia i've
everywhere everywhere you can think of
because it was something to keep you
busy like
if you weren't like you with comics you
could go up every night and work on your
craft with as an actor if you don't have
a job you don't have a job so you have
to do the scene study classes i i would
have like two and three going at a time
i used to have scene study my roommate
was a an actor so we would do scene
study classes on our own
like it was just always it was
everything i thought of and then i'd
wait tables at the comedy store at night
and break everybody's balls
and they were like why aren't you doing
stand-up and then 12 years later after
waiting tables all that time it finally
hit me maybe i should do stand-up
and it's been 10 years
you believe out 10 years i've been doing
this already
good for you february 10 years but you
know what bro you went but like i could
have started when i was 21 when i
[__] came here yeah but you know what
you i wasn't there yet you sat you
watched you saw what the life was about
and i hated it inside look at it
you know no and listen nobody picks this
[__] line this this life is i knew
how bad it was i knew how brutal the
road was for punishment man yeah the
first five years
unless you luck out you know and i i am
blessed yeah opening for andrew no no no
but that is a big
blessing in that first couple years
like he he put me on the road with him
and then i got booed off the stage so he
let me go for that one year to really
see if i was gonna keep doing it
and i did
and then he brought me back and i've
been with him kind of consistent ever
since you got booted off the stage how
much of an education was that good let
me tell you the theater in the round
westbury music fair
in long island
so they're booing you from the front the
side you won't even drive past that
place ever again no i'll [__] kill
you you won't even go to london
no i i kill it governor my goal is to go
back to westbury and [__] destroy
them
because i was so nervous i was sweating
so bad on stage that my i had a cute
little half bra i'm just running now i'm
telling them yeah just
and
i was like holding my hands under here
anyway so uh i'm my bra i had a cute
little half top like a half bra on under
my cute shirt and it slid down dude and
it looked like [__] tumors on my
stomach that's how much you were
sweating sweating so about seven minutes
of it just booing
booing they put it on my space nobody
has an idea what
what dying is for seven minutes
seven minutes it takes this quick this
is seven minutes this quick yeah but
when you're done
it's two and a half hours maybe four
years
even if you have three minutes and
you're dying at the first minute you
don't know what [__] and they're
going oh [__] you
are you still telling jokes like five
minutes in yeah i say i'm from philly
[__] the phillies like they play for the
yankees or the [__] giants or
whatever they're [__] you the eagles
stink they start run off sports teams
i'm like what the [__] and i'm throwing
out a few good lines i think i had like
two or three good lines and then i
remember like catching eyes with my
sister she drove all the way up from
south philly thank god she didn't bring
her friend georgie martin god rest his
soul but he he if he would have been
there he would have [__] killed at
least
1 000 people was his sister bowing but
no my sister she should have but she
stood up and my sister we look exactly
alike but we're 10 years apart she just
looked at me like what do you want to do
i want to fight this whole [__] room
i'll start writing this section you know
what i mean like just two south philly
animals ready to just take on long eyes
it was brutal it was so
and that's when he was like i gotta see
if because he wasn't gonna go on stage
andrew and i went upstairs and i was
like just go out there they don't want
to see me it has nothing to do with my
act they just want to see you and like
i'm trying to be brave i'm like go out
there and then he went out he had the
best set ever because he just [__] all
over
everybody and
like he was how dare you [__] treat
her like that she's my family you know
what i mean like he was so angry
but i also was dressed wrong it was bad
it was no it was an education three
months into stand-up oh yeah you're not
ready for [__] westbury the nerve of
me to go to [__] westbury music fair
to follow two opening comics by the way
and then we took an intermission and
then i went out
but we had
oh yeah they threw
because we had the vh1 show on no so he
his brain is
1989.
so in 89 when you're on tv they love you
because there was four channels in there
i have vh1 and [__] long island oh it
got i think they [__] canceled the
whole network
miracle no no no no no brutal brutal
that was terrible positioning it was
brutal that was even a [__]
experienced guy after an intermission
it's gotta be somebody high energy even
the two guys on before me to wake him up
into missions when somebody calls me for
a theater show with four or five comics
the first question out of my mouth is
who's opening up after the intermission
where would you rather go i'll tell you
what i will do it now i'll tell you what
i'd rather do how about let me close out
before the intermission check and i'm
going to stay there for the extra hour
and a half and that'll get beaten
that's where i want to be closing out
the first half if you're going to do an
intermission it's terrible
if you've got a big time headliner put
me on third to close up the intermission
or put me on before the headline in
which he won't want to do that
so i knew that was going to happen when
they would call me for those things
so i was always telling put me up
well we want to put you before that line
listen it's not going to work he's going
to ko it guarantees let's say no
sure enough the guy would call him yeah
you're right you're gonna
we decided we decided we decided he
didn't decide we decided that was a good
idea jojo we're gonna put you up
there it's brutal i can't even
like that doing that i would
intermission is the weirdest thing i've
ever [__] seen like i get it if
you're gonna do it and then just bring
out the headliner because then they're
gonna especially like a dice
because his crowds are so rowdy and like
we were just in boston on saturday the i
thought these guys when i came out they
looked at me like oh it's a sacrifice
we're just allowed to take her right
like i mean it was they were coming at
you and this was just saturday so it's
even worse when you're three months in
like andrew said he sat on the side and
watched me because he thought i was
gonna cut my set short that's how rowdy
the crowd was they're yelling [__] out
so i'm putting fires out this last week
just saturday night oh yeah yeah in
boston
but you just i'm saying they've been
waiting to still have to beat the [__]
out of them here's the thing
he opened with the poems that's how
[__] rowdy they were the poem if
you know you're a quarterback
when you're the first comic cop you're a
[__] quarterback
because you dictate the functions stay
in the pocket that's one thing i learned
at the comedy store on sunday night
that no matter who was going up
mitchy gave you the power to dictate the
show do a minute in between them
feel them out do a new joke
and something made me learn
how to shift them from one direction to
another a comet goes up there he's
[__] filthy
he's [__] filthy
and i know the guy behind him is gonna
be [__] clean i'm going to do family
material for a minute just to change
their mindset that's something i know
off the bat i'm not going to go up there
and carry on being [__] dirty
one thing i believe in
okay and this is rough coming out of my
mouth
i don't want the first guy or first girl
to be [__] dirty
no i get that i really don't want that
person to be dirty
you know when a promoter does that
you're telling me you're ignorant you're
putting three comments to the same if me
and eleanor come into your town it's got
to be a clean chick up front
clean spotless clean not a curse word
could come out of them because by the
time i go up there they've heard
everything
they're beating to death with curse
words
right
just like this there's not only stand up
there's a psychology to stand up and
where you go
when you go out in front of dice when i
used to go on with rogan
i'm the first guy out
yeah my first four minutes are clobbered
if they heckle i do not respond at all i
don't have time for a heckle
i'm like a
hat
the shit's hitting me and it's just
flying off and eventually
they [__] stop
yeah they [__] stop
that's what wheels does he talks over
them he says yeah you got to talk over
them yeah you got to talk over them
because if not
you're [__] uh
it just doesn't [__] work yeah if you
react to those theater crowds they'll
eat you up alive well that's what i'm
saying they just yeah
you're like think of those [__]
there's too many fires think of those
pilot to bombardier guys
that used to open up for [__] sam
kennison oh yeah
i mean like think of those pilot to
bombardier guys
it's like it's like opening up for artie
lang when he was on
howard stern oh yeah that crowd comes in
juiced up on [__] method at the met
to do hauling company they got
everything in their [__] veins
you think they want to put up with an
opener they yell and scream and you know
we come back from the that show happened
in philly with the bill burr and people
saying that oh yeah well the worst
audience i ever seen in a music crowd
was philadelphia sammy hagar was up on
stage they came and they were spitting
on their fingers and flinging the spit
off their fingers in 1982 81
philadelphia was brutal
and philadelphia is always brutal here's
the thing man
i always believe in the control you have
on stage
if they get like that it's because you
didn't do your job right
somewhere you did something you came out
cocky
yeah you did something i've seen
tremendous comics
can't follow their uh
intro
oh yeah like they've made the intro so
powerful
that now people are expecting smoke
you know it backfires on you i kind of
got in trouble for that once yeah
david's hill it backfires on only
because i'm such a big fan
that i brought i was hosting and i was
thrilled you know
he got me in that tempe improv and so
rest in peace i know [__] he was
[__] nuts god i loved him but anyway
so he got me that gig and i i gave a
tell this
amazing and he pulled me aside and he's
like
honey i can't no no
i'm so sorry like because i don't want
to get fired
but you know you have to you got to be
careful yeah no no it's like [__] i
can't follow up keep it short keep it
quick get in and out
boom boom boom you can't sit there
they're one of the funniest things i
ever did ever
and i hope i don't know where this guy
is today this guy was one of the
when you write your your comedy memoirs
he has to be in there he was a guy
el paso was one of the best weeks i had
okay well that was that medium feature
act uh-huh okay
freddie everybody did el paso oh yeah he
was
a tremendous connection still is i kind
of think it still is but the club has
changed he's changed a lot of things
have changed
but when he was in the earl club the
first one
i forgot what the trainer thought was
what the [__] are we talking about i'm
doing the circuit in el paso
oh uh
just following an intro
okay so
el paso had this dude that cleaned up at
night okay he had the contract at the
movie theater
he had the contract of the restaurant
and that was his last contract so he
would start at the
at the [__] uh
comic strip and i'll pass away go
sweep the floors vacuum
hand wipe the tables clean the bar clean
the bathrooms take out the garbage and
then from there you go to the movie
theater sweep the whole movie theater
the bathrooms him and his wife were a
team okay and then from there they ended
up at a restaurant where they'd
steam the mats and the whole thing the
guy told me his life but one day he goes
[__] it i'm gonna become a stand-up
comedy
okay
he started busting
the owner's balls for [__] mc spots
so between you and i and the guy had
personality he was a [__] stranger
was he funny or just he just felt like
he knew he knew everybody in el paso
so a hundred people come together so he
knew the lingo yeah and he knew little
things and
one night he opened up for george lopez
and george lopez told me he was a star
so he was off and running i got that he
had a suit up for that he was going to
dump his wife for another woman
the whole [__] thing this guy was
hysterical
be well
he's still cleaning the club at night
right so
he's walking around like [__] frank
sinatra
and i get down there
and the first thing the owner bart god
bless this song he's a great dude come
calls me over he goes listen
when he comes over and asks you for a
resume
write out two pages
oh you i see like for an intro yeah so i
think that's
hysterical at night i had to go to my
[__] condo right you know born in
cuba
migrated to new york at the age of three
went to captain school
oh yeah and i gave it to you basically
your bio he opens it up and he's like
reading through it and he comes up he's
like you want me to say all this
i'm like yeah the headliner had like a
eight page
the first weekend with him we tortured
him
like an eight page and he went up to the
first night wednesday night in this
[__] [__]
rather we're in the back howling
howling people and he can't even and
they said in the announcer voice yeah
with these coming to the stage
this guy played billy basketball
for the six street devils
this sick stream table he wasn't fond of
the uniform
we would crack him
every comic that went that game a page
resume every week
every time he hosted we tormented that
guy but the still doing stand up no
no no
breakdown we broke them
we broke them on new year's eve
[Laughter]
happy new year
we broke him how he was the janitor we
took those things you drop in the floor
confetti
his vacuum didn't pick it up you just
gave me a flashback you broke him at his
job
he gotta pick up
each piece of [__] face
with his fingers he said he was there
for 20 hours straight him his wife the
kids
everybody pick something up he quit
coffee [__] he closed up shop
he got a decent day job and that was the
end of that [__] memo
good you got him out man because
otherwise we'd still be dealing with
that piece of [__] oh my gosh that was
such a fun some people stay in it that's
what we were talking about earlier too
that you stay in it
and you don't
like know when to get out i was down
there
a lot
one thing about bart god bless him when
i was a feed tract he put me down at two
weeks of the shot and every time there
was a cancellation i'd get the call
so there was a time period for like six
months i would go down there and that
guy hosted three or four nights and by
that time every time i went
like i said he started off as a janitor
yeah and by like the
second time before i didn't see him
anymore he started wearing suits
and he was booking an army base it was
hysterical transformation
he was booking a restaurant he talked to
pablo francisco
about doing a theater with him in tucson
he mentioned my name i mean this guy was
a big shot
and then i got a hold of him those two
weeks before new year's
i got him with the resume
[__]
gum in the chairs
i went and bought packs
[Laughter]
he would i would come in he said he had
a scrape to go come out yeah
[__] he was doing this
i did that for the final week and then
the final week i started sprinkling
graffiti and he kept saying no way
you're an [__] that's too much
[Laughter]
putting graffiti on the fly i don't know
oh my god his playgroup on the floor
like a little bit i'd put like 100 i
would have killed you like that's a
movie where like the guy snaps and he's
like
it is it is like
glitter or whatever it was and here's
the beauty that he went to the
management and said to them listen guys
i gotta tell you something oh my god
even the high-powered vacuums
won't pull
the things
from your floor confetti yeah don't do
it get the pop bottle and that's it
because the strings are easier to pick
up things easier they agreed trust me i
had to do it they went out and bought
the cops 22 000 pop bottles but that
didn't stop joey diaz
as soon as this is a happy new year i
started flinging that [__] from a bag
nobody do nothing the purple lights
everything was dark
that dude came in that night my phone
rang that morning and a dog
who the [__] drew graffiti up in the
floor last night i have no idea though
yeah i can't i was too busy doing on
stage doing comedy jesus christ i'm
[__] up me and my family are still
here picking up little things
the club was closed for two days they
were there those two days wow picking
each thing up one by one i mean that's
and they stick to your fingers they
stick you can't get them out of the car
listen i hear juan carlos at the comedy
store just cursing is he still there oh
yeah
you see the problem is miss mitzi
eleanor
i love let me [__] uh read the shout
out to you
i got to give a special thanks to james
croot
for really helping out with my niece's
campaign
i love you to death james thank you for
what you do random bossio gregory
harrison
joey crookland what's happening
phil castillo youssef gough
kirkar serrati
ray dwack
and music while boozing podcasts
i got you [__] you know what i'm
saying
we got you
don't forget next uh wet thursday friday
saturday the party starts thursday night
at the pittsburgh improv in homestead
i know they say pittsburgh impairments
to impress you but it's really in
homestead don't forget
september 28th to the 30th pittsburgh
improv homestead homestead i've heard
nice things about homestead it's nice i
like it i'm looking forward to you know
i've never been to pittsburgh that's how
silly i am
it's only six hours away from
philadelphia i gotta take a plane
no i mean i will [__] fly oh yeah
it's pretty quick that way i landed
philly on wednesday i go to the hospital
get a hotel room go to dinner with my
brother smoke a couple of balls and
then thursday i wake up i eat the free
breakfast there you go i just take the
shuttle to the [__] airport and uh
bubble do the first show thursday night
friday two shows saturday i come back
i'm home for two weeks then i go to
tampa improv
nice and then that following week we're
only gonna do one podcast
on monday night because i'm leaving too
quick so
uh
that's true so you mean like because
you're going back-to-back right i got it
yeah that's the hardest part yeah when
you leave on wednesday it's a little on
the rub side for me but
i gotta tell you something
you're paying me
i committed to doing a job
you know what i'd feel a lot better if
you came in on the day before i agree on
both of these i'm not getting killed one
day i leave at two and the other
flight's at two perfect so at least i
take mercy to school yeah i eat
breakfast with my wife you know
lax is not that
that bad at that time i'm not [__]
dying yeah the only thing i don't think
about those flights and they're usually
delayed
really the one o'clock yeah
455 which ain't bad you go get a nice
lunch you already ate an edible
so you're on fire at the airport you
know what i'm saying i get [__] up
trust me this lasts oh my god on the way
to [__] oklahoma this week
i got
just
ripped out of my mind by mistake eleanor
what you like you took too much here's
what happened but you you know i take
these things at night the transmission
fluid
so we ate two of them a piece these
transmission fluids are a killer
the last one for your car or your body
no they're thinking that they're edibles
but i call them transmission fluids
cause they clean everything out no they
smell just like transmission like if you
drip the oil from a transmission that
all that comes up
this is exactly what it smells like so
anyway they make a long story short
so i gotta go on [__] friday morning
the show's on saturday i want to get
there early i want no problems it's
tornado alley
they only have a direct on friday at 10
in the morning it gets me to 3 o'clock
i have the guy pick me up at 7 30.
i get in the [__] car i already had a
protein shake and my wife makes
scrambled eggs one piece of toast
and two little pieces of bacon i'm on
the wait watch the [__] thing in the
morning she's driving me crazy but it's
working
i [__] uh get in the car i talk to
lee
and i go oh i packed two of them for the
flight two of them which you gotta be
crazy
it's 7 30 in the morning which is late
for you
it's like it's 7 7 30. yeah
yeah he'll take edibles at 3am i'll take
him at three if i'm gonna fly out at six
someone like about to expect when you
fire that six that means you're gonna be
in the air for [__] five hours you
gotta be prepared you gotta time your
edible just correct the mundo
so it peaks at the three hour point so
at the three-hour mark you gotta
actually sit down and go
should i jump off the plane
or do i wanna watch another movie you
know that's the feeling wait do you stay
awake on the plane oh yeah i can't sleep
i gotta sleep roams
oh my god that's brutal so i gotta make
the best of it but when i go to new york
i understand when i go to new york a
boss and i take [__] mint
yeah
that's what we took on the way back and
i plugged that [__] in
and i plug plug that sleep apnea machine
and i slide that little door in
i put that little sleep apnea mask after
they bring me that [__] breakfast on
yeah
i put that bed all the way back i fold
up my sweatshirt as a pillow
you put the air on your head uh-huh and
it's happy noodle time somebody always
slips me a pill in new york
somebody always switch me a pill in new
york or two we took that home from
boston
i break that in half i put it under my
tongue after breakfast
but all i'm hearing is we're about to
descent
pull your seats up you're like [__]
but this week was completely different
i guess well oklahoma's shorter right
three and a half three and a half okay
i get on the [__] plane i get i'm in
the [__] uber
i'm talking to the guy
i go what am i going to eat this other
boy start to get to the airport fast
because after you pass a certain point
there ain't no traffic on the floor yes
yes it's pretty [__] up you're like
what is it after you pass uh sunset
sunset you're it's it's now you're doing
it everyone's getting off everyone's
getting off and then you're [__] and
like right around the when the four or
five and ten meet for a second yeah
anytime there's another right right
right right they don't know the first
one is sunset the second one is the 10
after the 10
you're the only one in the hov lane the
cops won't even pull you over yeah
it'll start around like santa monica
maybe it's [__] crazy
i keep a baby
i just hit the 10
and i go let me pop this edible it's got
to be five to eight
i popped this whole 200 milligram now
this thing hits if i eat it at night
it hits me for about a half hour 45 what
are you talking about it's me look at me
do i look [__] [__] up to you yes
yes all right anyway
to make a long story short i'm gonna hit
you
i'm sorry i get to the airport and i'm
checking in and i already feel it
hitting me
i only had [__] eggs
i only had eggs so i get upstairs i get
through there it's terminal five i see
lemonade guys okay and i go in and i get
oatmeal and a [__]
watermelon
lemonade yeah not the lemonade rest i
think it's called something else okay
it's not lemonade it's called something
else but their specialty is
old-fashioned lemonade
i always have the rosemary whatever
lemonade fancy i never eat the eggs and
all that [__] i always eat the [__]
oatmeal's delicious what they've done to
eleven yeah let me tell you something by
the time i got on that plane i put that
like that [__] i uh
i put an ipad on whatever the [__] it is
i start listening to music you know
saying before i get off before the plane
even takes off
i already listened to what happened
the [__] plane takes off i gotta take
some 30 minutes in the air
i can feel my [__] i am getting
[__] objects
anything get no better i'm going what do
you do what if you have an anxiety
attack i got two pills in the bag i got
everything in the bag toothbrush
blood pressure medication two xanax one
ambien i got more [__] in that bag than
[__] a pharmacy i'm like drugstore
cowboy yeah i'm like matt dylan and
drugstore cowboy joey pharmaceuticals
because i know i'm gonna have an anxiety
attack anything from those edibles yeah
i also got a vapor pen i'm prepared but
i always i have a prescription for
anxiety medication i just really never
[__] take it unless i'm i haven't
taken edibles i'm afraid edibles will
give me a little anxiety so there's a
point where
you've got to level up anxiety but no
let me tell you something i don't drink
alcohol on the planet i don't do nothing
i just chomp in this nicotine gum and i
drink water like a [__] dog
and i get feasizzled do you understand
me
i get [__] up
we land i'm [__] lit
i mean when we landed i was [__] lit
i'm gonna get into the airport going ooh
it's only three in the earth and then i
got a dilemma here i got on that [__]
thing me and kate drove the indians
nice little indian lady and the driver
drove us to the thing
i went to my room i don't know and it
was the first time in a long time i
didn't know what to do with myself
i was walking around the room with my me
undies on right
with socks
with no shirt do you remember which
design was it like the camo the
camouflage the green camera perfect
because i always fly with sweatpants on
now
i got some nice [__] uh uh gear
from those people that make the the
sports stuff immediately
you know the sweatshirt i gave you mike
tyson and stuff oh right um roots of
fighting roots are fine
last week great
excuse me
and they always send me sweat gear
so
i mean they sent me two pants these
sweatpants so i wear one to go there and
one to come back
no more [__] belt than nothing
i put a white t-shirt on to look nice
ironed you know me old school yeah
philadelphia napolitano and i put a
sweatshirt on a hooded sweatshirt so i
look decent
let me tell you something at the two
hour mark i was on fire on that plate
it was fast too i didn't either had the
computer with the well you got the
lemonade right it's cause the sugar i
don't know it don't matter i was on fire
we land we go back to the hotel room
i don't know what to do i said [__] i'm
gonna take a shower and go downstairs
and he had a bunch of plans
right before i wanted to shower this
[__] had a bunch of people i had a
bunch of plans done i was gonna do this
then i was gonna go hang out with the
indians
smoke the peace pipe right play wheel of
fortune
[__] uh get go to the steakhouse yeah
the next thing you know i had this
creepy tiredness lurking over me and i
go you know what let me put the sleep
apnea machine together
i put that sleep apnea machine together
i looked in the thing and there was a
little bag i forgot they gave me a
chocolate chip oatmeal coconut cookie
when i checked in
i [__] took that little chocolate
oatmeal cookie and i've been into that
[__] and i had a valium in it
and dog i snuck from 4 30 to 7 30.
i woke up i woke up
i [__] took a shower i got i called
kate she said she passed out i was still
high when i went to dinner
i killed it then i had a cup of soup
a salad
a six ounce filet and a lobster tail
and a piece of bread with butter there
you go oh that [__] that that
transmission fluid had me going
for a whole day that's crazy the whole
[__] day 200 milligrams
usually i hate 200 milligrams nothing
happens it's like a [__] walk in the
park like on a barbie d phone called
joey you know what's sad i don't take
anything i don't do any drugs i sit on
the plane the minute they start that
[__] thing i'm out like a light
god bless you until they land sometimes
they have to wake me up the only time i
ever took something was when we went to
australia
because it's like a 15-hour flight
uh my ex gave me like um i think it was
valium it's the first time i ever took
it
but he's like i started having anxiety
about flying over seat like over water
because you know i never leave the
states
you know so i don't we don't go over
so i started panicking like oh [__] okay
i like i don't mind if we go down and
hit land but if we hit water
i'm terrified of the ocean that's
perfect the shark will be right there to
bite you down i hope so nobody [__]
loses nothing but in my head it gives
you anxiety i'm sorry i'm sorry it's
fine everything's fine in the airplane
but it gives you anxiety so your brain
starts [__] so i'm like 15 hours i
can't sit sit still for 15.
i'll sign up for that [__] i know i
don't give a [__] what interesting let
me tell you i don't give a [__] what
type of people how interesting they are
what's the football is it vicodin is it
or value i don't know they make it okay
so there's a football i took a timing or
a sonic shield
okay i took a tiny piece of that i slept
after i filled out the [__] form they
make you fill out whatever here's your
form lady i put the blanket on me i
slept they woke me up when we landed
good for you
the guy when he we were getting off the
guy that was sitting next to me that
tried to talk to me in the beginning i'm
like it's not going to work for you
buddy i'm out like i have anxiety i'm a
[__] mess i'm woozy
i always say that like i woke up and i'm
like [__] did i just get raped by bill
cosby like that's how high i was for 15
hours
[__] hours and then the guy like
we're walking out and it was all like
these crew guys they were i forget who
it was miley cyrus or somebody they work
for so they were walking out and
they were meeting up with each other as
we were walking out and the one guy said
to the other guy oh how was your flight
he goes that was good he goes
she slept the whole way like he was
talking about i can hear you [__] but
i did i on the way back i woke up the
last two hours
and that that was that's not bad that
wasn't terrible but wake up you look at
the clock you have two hours left you're
like god damn but i definitely lost a
chunk of my brain from that sex because
i put me out
i'm a weak you know i'm an easy uh
target if anybody wants to drug me i'm
just like you know listen man i'm happy
you took the time to come on tonight
you got balls of steel always a pleasure
i love it thank you you'll host the
comedy store with what's his name rick
ingram and i we host the comedy store
podcast use every week we have every
week yeah
yeah sometimes it's a pain in the ass
because like you said we're traveling i
was just going for 12 days and then in
august i was out for like two and a half
weeks on the east coast i took a little
vacation with my family and did some
gigs i was supposed to
uh roast pete rose and it got cancelled
because he was uh apparently he [__]
us and a few other underage girls so
some [__] went down
but that would have been fun man he's
what an easy target they never stop on
pete
poor [__] pete bro it never ends with
my boy pete nobody knows how much i love
pete as a young man pete man everything
to me and this is the hardest worker
there's somebody told me he was cuban
and i lost my mind i go who [__] told
you he goes i'm telling you my teacher
told me that baron
i love that
he says he's cuban he was like well when
did you see that he goes i saw him one
night talking like a stomach hurt
he looks like he goes
his name is pedro rosario oh and i
[__] died dawg i went home told my
mother you know pete rose cuber says
like get the [__] out of here go to your
room
anyway talking about [__] movie stars
we all want to eat better but when it
comes to snacks
sometimes it feels like the whole world
is delicious and a billion calories
versus boring and tasteless
it doesn't have to be that way up your
snack game with nature bucks
nature box has over 100 snacks
that taste tremendous and they're good
and they're actually better for you all
snacks are made high quality
simple ingredients which means no
artificial colors
flavors or sweetness so you can feel
good about what you're eating which is
where these days
okay now when i get a little little
nature box i'll tell you what i like to
munch on all right oh my god the
chocolate nom noms
until this day the salt and pepper
lentils are delicious the crispy coconut
squares the double chocolate brownie
cookies the whole wheat vanilla animals
i'm telling you right now
you have no idea what you're missing
you're sure to find your new snack
obsession at naturebox they add new
snacks every month inspired by real
customer feedback and the latest food
trends and professional chefs it's so
simple here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna go to nationbox.com
choose the snacks you want and nature
box will deliver them right to your door
number two there's no risk
if you ever want to try a snack you
don't like
don't eat it nature box will replace it
for free
so if you ever try a snack and you don't
like it
don't eat it nature box will replace it
for free what we're going to do is this
right now i'm going to save you even
more nature boxes off in the church or
what's happening now family
three free snacks with your first order
when you go to naturebox.com
joey again
that's naturebox.com joey the first
three free snacks with your first order
naturebox.com
joey it's time that you ate a lot better
number two let me tell you something if
you look through my drawers
you won't see no [__] tiny
whities [__]
those days are over with yeah they're
nice they they're cheap they're tight
but after a while they feel like dick
let me tell you something ever since
you've been a kid
those underwears feel like dick
especially
after you put on a pair of me undies let
me tell you some about me undies you
want to look good right
you want to look good you're in the way
and you want to be comfortable that's
the most important thing you don't want
to be reaching for your nutsack and
pulling [__] out all day
but the perfect balance is hard to find
don't sacrifice style or comfort check
out meundies.com
and find the best pair underwear in the
world
me on these will be the most comfortable
pair underwear you ever own i'm telling
you this is your [__] uncle joey made
from sustainable source naturally
soft fabric that is three times softer
than cotton
ultimate feels good on these for when
you want to feel naked
not be naked you follow me the ultimate
feel good undies for when you want to
feel naked and not be naked
for the fellas me undies
diamond seam pouch cradles your jewels
and gives you stuff to support it needs
without feeling too tight if you know
what i'm talking about
ladies will love that soft
eco-friendly fabric
so soft and touchable you follow me
it's 100
satisfaction guarantee they guarantee
you'll love your undies or guess what
you'll get your money back what i'm
going to do is this right now
meundies has an exclusive offer just for
the church family again get 20 off your
first pair and
free shipping did you hear that 20 off
your first pair and free shipping and me
undies are so sure you'll love the
underwear
they're even gonna offer you 100
satisfaction guarantee you order a pan
if you don't love the first pair you get
your full refund it's a no-brainer 20
off free shipping and 100 satisfaction
guarantee who do you think you're
dealing with what the hell are you
waiting for to get the 20 off free
shipping and 100
and get the best and softest underwear
you'll ever know do me a favor go to
meundies.com joey again
that's meundies.com
joey there's a limited time only 100
percent guarantee satisfaction free
shipping and 20 off so what the hell are
you waiting for start wearing the best
underwear of your life
it's changed mine all right it's time to
get the me undies change
go to meundies.com
joey right now i want to thank
nature box me undies eleanor kerrigan
and my main man lisa you bad
[__] i'll see you [__]
wednesday night
or not i'll see you in pittsburgh next
thursday have a great week i'll talk to
you [__] wednesday night stay
black
[Music]
you